let's jump to this next story what i
have before you my friends is youtube's
covered misinformation policy the funny
thing about this is i'm like you know
the the most of the code stuff's over
like the mandates are mostly over the
u.s still require vaccines for entry but
they don't actually check so it's
actually the airlines who are requiring
and then some people here's a funny
thing tons of people everybody who
travels knows this
they're like you don't fly to united
states anymore you fly to tijuana and
then walk in
just walk in they don't check they don't
care it's the weirdest gap in security
and policy or whatever but anyway here's
the point
youtube's medical misinformation policy
when you scroll down to prevention
misinformation doesn't mention anything
about masks in fact i will do this in
real time control f and we'll type in
m-a-s-k nothing the word mask does not
appear in youtube's misinformation
policy anymore so i tweeted this youtube
updated its policies to no longer ban
claims that masks do not play a role in
preventing the spread of covet
essentially you are now allowed to claim
masks don't work so we can see
initially it used to say this
claims that masks do not play a role in
preventing the contraction or
transmission of covet 19 you are not
allowed to say that
youtube removed that and uh
i'm assuming you can now say it
here's what they say i'll let you say it
first because i got all kinds of
censorship oh no period of time in my
life i'm good the it says that the um
the google uh misinformation policy
youtube's policies on cove 19 are
subject to change in response to changes
to global or local health authority's
guidance in the virus there may be a
delay between new lha and who guidance
and policy updates given the frequency
with which his guidance changes and our
policies may not cover all lha and who
guidance related to covid you know this
is this is a serious problem that
scientists
have been saying this very thing
and youtube was banning them
rand paul came out dude's a doctor they
they just they gave him a strike on
youtube for bringing this up if a doctor
can't even talk about it which doctor
can
youtube has arbitr arbitrarily chosen
the world health organization as their
end-all be-all for what is true and
correct
this is extremely dangerous
because the world health organization is
a political entity not a medical one it
is a political international entity not
a medical body it is not like an
academic group of doctors at a
university doing clinical trials it is a
political institution and youtube's like
they'll be the experts do you think
that's because they feel like they are
obligated to listen to a global
authority because they view themselves
as a global platform even though it's
based in the us i think for for uh
youtube it's the easy way out yeah the
world health organization they have
their their pictures they sound good
enough no no they actually work with a
bunch of countries therefore it's easier
to use them as a standard so that we
don't get in trouble with other
countries well how do we pick our
arbitrators for other fact checking you
know you had the was it the washington
post we're not watching for new york
times and other periodicals that were
being sent
articles to see if it was political
misinformation if it was scientific
misinformation it didn't have to just be
about masks but either you're going to
have complete censorship or you have no
censorship and the complete censorship
needs a lot of oversight and we're not
there and that's the idea that you're
not going to have a platform that's
perfect you know there's things that we
can all agree on that exploitation of
children violence you know extremism in
some sort of way of like
cause for violence basically calls for
violence yeah those are generally
accepted no-no's it's when we get into
these gray areas that you you take a
hard-line stance and you ruin businesses
you ruin people's lives the the problem
is
some people argue for free speech
absolutism meaning you they they argue
you could you know call for violence
because you didn't actually do anything
and i get it
if the idea is
you know we don't allow a
speech that calls for violence because
that's a crime
well that's not an argument because then
all that has to happen is they decide
another kind of speech is a crime
okay well now you know insulting someone
or not in their pronouns is assault or
violence and thus now they can say well
that's not free speech you're committing
a crime right so there is there is an
issue in at what point does speech
become illegal and can it and a question
of shouldn't it just be on you to defend
yourself
i i would think so but we we have seen
that it becomes a safe haven you know a
place where people can congregate and
start creating organizations and a
movement of violence and extremism and i
i think you know it's very similar and
has some connotations to
afghanistan and people had an argument
of we don't need to be there there's no
uh objective for us but it allowed for a
safe haven of horrible individuals to
congregate plan and execute atrocious
acts you know in my opinion you need to
have some oversight but it's not
living there 24 7 it's pinpoint
action taken towards those individuals i
don't i don't think there's
a solution at all uh
so they want to censor people because
you know people are offensive or
whatever
we start we we all agree like hey don't
incite violence don't tell people to
commit violence don't tell them how to
commit violence we agree that's a bad
thing the issue though is now from that
point they've moved on to the next point
stochastic terrorism well now you're
saying things that will
infer the idea or convince someone to go
do something well that's calling for
violence that's where they're at now and
they and they will eventually ban that
i'm not entirely sure they can i'm
saying their goal is to get that kind of
speech banned where if you said
something like
we should shut that school down because
of the horrible things they do they say
hey we know what you're getting at it's
uh won't someone rid me of this
meddlesome priest thing and that's what
they're trying to argue now because
people like james lindsey and libs of
tiktok have been criticizing these these
uh hospitals that have been doing you
know surgery on these kids they're
saying oh that's stochastic terrorism
and their goal is to rally people to to
eventually go and do something it's like
there's no line you can keep ramping it
up until eventually you've banned all
species just cause you're afraid doesn't
mean that i made you afraid like just
because someone's in terror doesn't mean
that someone else committed a
terroristic act terror is a very
well i don't know i think it's very
hardcore i mean if you're you're making
people fear for their life without other
than words in the united states it's an
imminent threat of violence not just
threats of violence not like hey go
something something it's when you give a
date and a time and a place that creates
an imminent threat and that is illegal
in the united states you're allowed to
say like hey go
fill in the blank not i'm not talking
about youtube i'm talking about american
civil liberties uh but you cannot call
for imminent threats of violence i think
that social networks that are based in
the united states should follow american
law personally that's what mines does oh
they follow the world health
organization instead
uh then i think we should take the keys
away
um and maybe free up the space a little
bit because private companies should not
be getting in the way of the country
that helped them create themselves and
individuals who find themselves wronged
in every way shape or form and there's
settings out there you can make yourself
private you can ban everyone from being
on your page you can just get off of
social you know that's one of those
things where i'd like to tell people if
it's really causing you this much
anxiety and this much heartache one it
might be you two you have options to
just turn it off
it's it's it's not that big of a deal
but when we start infringing upon
everyone else's rights just to make you
happy that's where i draw a line you
know just get off of social if it's the
fact that people aren't adjusting by the
right pronouns if people aren't
addressing you by the right
fill in the blank and now you're on a
rampage and now it's your social justice
warrior and i have to placate to that
and i don't want to and that's really
what it boils down to is you you just do
you let me do me and i think if we could
ever get back to that point you know we
would be a much happier society but
right now we just hone in on the
negatives we try to
impose our opinions on other people as
opposed to saying hey you know we have a
difference of opinion that's fine that's
why i like to
fight overseas against terrorists who
don't allow you to have a different
opinion you talk about all the bad
things here go to those other countries
where you get stoned to death
what about intercourse with someone else
what about the terrorists that are here
trying to stop you from being able to
say whatever say what you want and have
an opinion and the ones who are running
big companies and defending those people
those are domestic terrorists in my
humble opinion hopefully that's gonna be
kicked off who are you talking about
like when you know blm or antique will
show up and throw a brick through your
window because you said not yet i think
they are domestic terrorists people that
will destroy property and threaten life
for a social movement i think are would
i would consider them terrorists
consider george washington a terrorist
king george did at the time yeah there
was a meme going around where um
these people are posting like trump
should remember you know this is what
they do to traders and it was a guy
being hanged the funny thing though is i
was like it was redcoats hanging a
minuteman a con or not a mini man but
continental army you know you know blue
coat and then i was just like
this the the treason you're showing was
against the crown like it was the
americans being like yo we don't believe
in monarchy and so they said that's
treason and these people are sharing
that as if
like it's a good thing to uphold because
it shows that fighting oppression is no
longer the mainstream it's now
everyone wants to be subjugated they
want to be told what to do they want to
be told you know that that everything
that's not good with you everything
that's gone wrong in your life it's not
you it's not your lack of effort it's
not your
work effort
it's everyone else's and that we need to
take things and give to
this group um yeah i i think that's a
slippery slope that we're headed just
out of curiosity were you ever on any
alternative platforms like mines or gab
or i don't even know what those are
they're just alternatives to i don't
know any social media platform or
twitter no i'm probably the world's
worst on uh getting on social and and
trying to stay engaged i i do try to
um you know connect with my my kids try
to connect with my uh fan base but uh
you know this is one of those things
that's it's kind of foreign to me you
know i'm a guy who'd rather be out in
the woods and be completely disconnected
from the world thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you